[Music]
my name is Lisa Roche and I lead our
data for social and environmental impact
initiatives here at Google cloud and
very excited to talk to you all today
about the circular economy
sustainability and the opportunities to
advance sustainability with technology
and also to kick off an exciting panel
discussion as well now before we
actually jump into the circular economy
more specifically and in particular I
want to take a step back and actually
talk a little bit more about you know
what sustainability really is why are we
talking about why is it important today
so kind of setting the stakes in 2018
the global demand for resources was 1.7
times what the earth can support in one
year between our agricultural energy and
consumption practices we are currently
consuming more resources than the earth
can support a circular economy aims to
redefine growth and focus on positive
society-wide benefits in three key ways
by designing out waste and pollution by
keeping products and materials and use
and even regenerating natural systems
now it's really at the core of the
circular economy is this idea of
decoupling economic growth from resource
use and it also has the opportunity to
generate four point five trillion
dollars of new economic output
especially when considering the advances
in technology that we have today
considering Shean learning and AI in
particular but what is a circular
economy what are tangible examples of a
circular economy well according to the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation who developed
the diagram that you see pictured here a
circular economy seeks to rebuild
capital whether that is financial
manufactured social or natural this
allows them for a continuous flow of
technical and biological materials or
nutrients into these value circles as
you can see they're quite broad
there are agricultural inputs there are
electronic inputs and as a result the
circular economy can take a variety of
shapes and forms it can be a bio-based
material for single-use food
Tanner's so what is pictured here is
actually an example of a disposable cup
made from the cassava root and so while
this is more environmentally friendly
and compostable it actually is additive
to the environment as well and helps to
promote soil regeneration a circular
economy can also be a rooftop hydroponic
based farm where one acre of previously
unused roof space can feed up to 2,000
people per year with fresh produce and a
circular economy is also an e recycling
model for electric vehicles as we know
there's an increasing demand for
electric vehicles and that is also
matched by an increasing demand for the
batteries that power them and there's
them the question of how can we recycle
the precious minerals materials etc that
went into making those batteries but
what our Google Cloud and si P doing
around sustainability how are we driving
innovation well looking at the
partnership more broadly Google Cloud
and si P announce our partnership in
2017 with the goal of giving customers
the best of both worlds essentially
unmatched business expertise
industry-leading cloud infrastructure
and machine learning solutions so
together we provide the flexibility and
the performance necessary in order to
drive impactful decisions for customers
around the world
we work together and we work for you now
in addition to this we can also help
organizations scale sustainably from
Google sustainable data centers where
100 percent of global energy use is
matched with renewable energy to the 91
percent landfill diversion rate that we
have achieved in 2017 and looking at si
P and their sustainable solutions what
they're working towards making wind
energy more cost-effective for example
with customers and also helping to
simplify risk management overall
together we believe that investing and
environmentally responsible management
means investing in a collaborative
future and that is where circular
economy 2030 comes in where Google cloud
and si P and now you I can come together
to create a more sustainable world
circular economy 2030 is a contest it is
a sustainability contest for social
entrepreneurs where we asked applicants
around the world to submit a proposal
for a revenue generating idea that
advances a circular economy and also SDG
12 one of the United Nations sustainable
development goals that range from taking
climate action to promoting gender
equality SDG 12 is focused on
responsible consumption and production
in particular and so it's very closely
tied to the concept of the circular
economy from the applicants the top five
eligible submissions are to receive
funding Google cloud credits and also
mentorship opportunities there's also an
additional phase of the competition that
is taking place this week an in-person
hackathon here in San Francisco this
weekend where the finalists will be
competing for the opportunity to win the
grand prize of $200,000 in in-kind
benefits across funding and cloud
credits in addition to the mentorship
opportunities and the Google cloud for
startups bootcamp experience and we're
not doing this alone it's not just
Google cloud and sa P we're also working
with leading ideas and nonprofits in
this space including UN Environment the
global partnership for sustainable
development data and the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation so with that we're about to
announce the finalists I'd like to
welcome my colleague Jim from s ap to
the stage thank you so much
wonderful so the finalists a quick note
before we dive in we received over 250
applications from over 50 countries
around the world which is really
exciting so the fun fact is every from
every continent except Antarctica which
is great and definitely spent a lot of
time reviewing these applications we
worked really hard on this also with an
interdisciplinary and cross-industry
panel of expert judges and are happy to
introduce them all to you today so the
first finalist the first social
entrepreneur is and runnel from reverse
resources focused on textile waste
reverse resources vision is to help
textile material flows reach their
highest potential their highest
environmental potential value so that
the need for new materials can be
minimized globally thanks the second
finalist is Dismas Kissel ooh and his
company is solar fries they are a
pioneering portable cold storage units
powered by solar energy for small-scale
room rule farmers of perishable products
so it's a company that's looking at the
food waste topic from a developing
country perspective and also converts
the waste into useful energy in bio
alcohol so exciting project absolutely
next is Jasmine Crowe founder of gooder
focus on food waste
the mission of gooders to reduce food
waste by connecting businesses that have
surplus food to those who need the meals
and fourth is Michael groves the company
is top oolitic switch is a smart grid
for the world's waste using big data
mapping and analytics to mace waste
management more transparent more
efficient and more effective both
commercially and for the environment and
then there's Patrick Peter founder of
circular mcc's focused on e waste the
mission of circular makes is to maximize
efficiency for the circular battery
economy with the goal of achieving zero
waste and with that we'd like to welcome
the panelists to the stage the remaining
panels to the stage for the discussion
portion of today's session so welcome
Kate Brant Google sustainability officer
Jim Sullivan who's already on stage head
of the global sustainability innovation
accelerator at sa P Darien Sturges
global partnerships manager at the Ellen
MacArthur Foundation and Alonso Ortiz
Galan Community Engagement Manager at
the global partnership for sustainable
development data
[Applause]
wonderful thank you all for joining
first and foremost to kick things off
would be great if you could tell us a
bit more about your work and background
in sustainability what drew you to this
work and why is it particularly critical
today
well huge congratulations to our winners
I think can we can we give them a round
of applause as we do a round of applause
for our winners Elyse is right I got to
serve as one of the judges and there was
some really stiff competition and some
other really exciting proposals so thank
you to everybody for participating and
we're thrilled to be here and it's been
such a great partnership with you
Germany SAV team yes so as a least
mentioned I serve as the Google
sustainability officer and circular
economy is something that I'm personally
really passionate about and that we have
been very focused on at Google so going
back to 2015 we made a commitment that
we wanted to embed circular economy
principles into our infrastructure our
operations our products and our culture
and a big part of making that commitment
was also our global partnership with the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation whom we've
worked with really closely ever since
then and for us this work really spans
across our operations from how we manage
our data centers that of course make
Google Cloud possible to our global real
estate portfolio our supply chain our
consumer hardware and also thinking
about the role of Google technology and
enabling everyone to accelerate this
transition to a circular economy and so
some of you noticed my favorite things
that we've been up to lately are looking
at the role of AI and accelerating the
transition to a circular economy we had
some really interesting applicants in
that space and we see this as a
tremendous opportunity to sort of
combine these megatrends for major
impact and we also are doing great work
in our data centers in this space
looking at how we can reuse
remanufacture or sell in secondary
markets different components of our
servers and really driving towards a
more circular data center ecosystem so
just a few things but I know we'll get
into more on the panel
hi there Darien sturgeon from the
MacArthur Foundation I would like to
echo some of Kate's thoughts on how
exciting it is I think from my
perspective to see the geographic
diversity of the finalists here this did
this this conversation about circular
economy can be a little bit esoteric and
at least in my experience a little
Eurocentric so seeing that there's some
take-up obviously in Europe but here in
the US and then in Africa is it's pretty
exciting so as I mentioned I lead us
partnerships for the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation which is an organization that
is about eight years old now with the
the mission statement of accelerating
the transition to a circular economy and
we can get into a little bit about what
that means later but the broad
brushstrokes are we work with
organizations around the world from the
private sector big global companies like
Google universities we work with the
public sector both of the city level and
the national level to drive change and
that runs the gamut from very tangible
projects Kate gave a few examples to
more thought leadership pieces about
what technology can mean for
sustainability in the circular economy
from cloud from artificial intelligence
etc so that's that's an overview of the
element kartha foundation again I'd like
to say it's great to be here and see so
much interest in the work thank you a
thank you for the invitation also very
excited to be here in San Francisco
guell next and to be pouring with this
exciting initiative and thank you all
for being here I know it's hard a
decision to like with everything all the
amazing panels going on so thank you I
am the Community Engagement Manager for
the global partnership for sustainable
development data and we are a global
network committing to ensure that we
have the necessary data to achieve and
monitor the SDGs
we bring together governments a civil
society multilateral yeren agencies and
the private sector together
to collect Li collectively solve a
problems and gaps around the production
and use of data we don't provide the
data ourselves or or collect data or
rather we provide strategic partnerships
advocacy a technical assistance and
pilot initiatives with partners from the
national regional and global level we
strive to reduce technical barriers but
also political ones so I have a
confession to make I'm a selfish
we're not live-streaming this are we
it's recorded oh we are good so I grew
up in upstate New York I love the
outdoors I love the winter I love skiing
cane and I just had a wonderful
conversation I got involved in the
climate change discussions probably 20
years ago because I love those outdoor
spaces and I'd like them to be available
for my lifetime but I've also had some
of the best times with my family with my
kids in the mountains hiking around
skiing and I want those spaces to be
available in their lifetimes as well
the second point my daughter as a is an
athlete his road crew for many years she
spends four or five hours a day on the
water in the rivers and you know comes
back with a report on what's floating
down the river that particular day so
two really sobering statistics on
climate change in the US alone 1.5
trillion dollars in damages from natural
weather events and disasters related to
extreme weather around that and then for
plastics I think everybody's heard the
stat there may be more fish than plastic
in the ocean by 2050 so on a personal
level I'm doing this for my kids for our
planet but it also needs to make a lot
of business sense
so from an SI p perspective for the past
47 years we have been managing had the
privilege to manage our customers
financial data flows and material data
flows we run seventy percent seventy
seven percent of financial transactions
flow through our systems on a daily
basis typically close to 80 percent of
material flows whether sneakers whether
plugging in your iPhone whether that and
if we can merge that data along with
environment and social data to allow
businesses throughout the world to make
better business decisions we can really
make a huge change in the in the world
so wonderful thank you for the
introductions and sharing more about
your interest and background in this
space so another question for you about
the circular economy it's a tough one to
define how would you define a circular
economy in a simplified way and how can
the circular economy help to navigate
the often inverse relation between
economic growth and environmental
degradation whoever wants to jump right
well I have to say I like the definition
of the circular economy that we've
gotten from the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation that it's about keeping
products and materials and use designing
out waste and pollution and regenerating
natural systems I think that to me feels
like a fairly concise way of
conceptualizing what I know can feel
feel like a very complex topic and and
and I really appreciate they also the
element as Jim was saying of the economy
in circular economy and Elise shared
some great statistics that I often cite
as well you know particularly the
Accenture study that showed us that
there's four point five trillion dollars
of value that could be realized by 2030
and what I love so much about this
competition and our fantastic winners on
all of you who applied is you're showing
this is a reality you're developing new
businesses new approaches that are
decoupling growth from our use of
natural resources you're showing that we
can build on all of the great work and
innovation that's taken place over the
last 200 years but chart an entirely
different course forward that is one of
abundance and one of a totally different
relationship to natural resources so I
really commend all the great work you
guys are doing and I think it's really
showing how we can put this theory into
practice in a really powerful way in a
way that makes business sense I would
add to that by saying at the foundation
at least we we tend to shy away from
defining specifically what the circular
economy is what we want to do instead is
provide more of a direction and
especially a positive direction I
at least mentioned the inverse
relationship between growth and resource
use and we want to provide more of a
positive framework that allows for
resource use without or I would say a
better use of the resources we have is
probably a another way of defining it
and I think the other slight
differentiation I would make is that we
think about a circular economy as an
upstream and a systems design issue
rather than just managing the symptoms
of the problem waste for example to us
it's it's the choices you make early on
in the process the materials you use
whether or not you design for single-use
servings such as the water bottles below
us that has impact and making those
choices early on in the process has a
much bigger exponential impact than just
trying to figure out what to do with the
plastic that that we pump out every year
at the end of at the end of its life the
final differentiation I would make is
thinking about things like consumption
in a slightly different way for instance
we tend to even shy away from sane
consumption thinking that you know you
don't really consume anything unless you
eat it so thinking about the resources
that businesses or individuals use as
materials that are going to be used over
and over again or at least can be used
over and over again rather than simply
consumed I think is another way of sort
of at least directionally getting at
what we mean by by the term circular
economy I think what's interesting about
circular economy is that it seems
something that's kind of revolutionary
and in the end it's because we married
to idea that the way we produce right
now is the only possible way we are just
so anchored on this power
them and I think it's very interesting
to see how many like this 5a finalists
are attempting to change that and I
think sometimes it's also about we think
it's only the solutions are only gonna
come from one sector for example
government pushing policies and pushing
everyone to comply but it's not about
that it's a win-win in which actually
businesses can benefit from inspecting
their processes and making a conscious
decisions about how to reduce costs
they're ways that they're inspect their
impact and how to think of how they
insert themselves in a brother ecosystem
and how they impact theirs themselves
and future generations I think it's a
from my thought I think it's really a
paradigm change and the reason so we've
been in the space for years and years of
ERP enterprise resource planning and
what you're really seeing is the
definition of Enterprise changing it
used to be if you did a good job in your
own four walls
check the box you're all set and now
consumers are demanding and transparency
was the kobold and my battery sourced
from slave labor or from child labor
what happens at the end of life it
doesn't go away anymore it goes into a
river and it goes somewhere so you know
from that definition you need to not
only take responsibility for your own
actions but your suppliers actions your
customers actions and how do you pull
all that together and the second thing
is the definition of a resource is
really changing in the past it was
enough to know form fit function and
we're good and of day and now we need to
know again the Associated attributes how
much water was used in the making of
this resource how much carbon was used
in the making of this resource what
happens to that resource at end-of-life
and increasingly I like to think of it
in stocks and flows if you look at some
of the circular statistics we're really
only cycling about 9% of materials
globally and some of those you know
maybe should be in place for a long
period of time but some of those if you
open a brand new good and you take the
packaging off and you throw the
packaging away you've engaged with that
material for all of five seconds and it
added very
value for you so it's just the way we
think about that so that's a bit of a
negative view the positive view is we're
in the age of hyper transparency with
data and if we can allow visibility into
those material flows that little
packaging that I threw away becomes a
valuable resource for somebody else in
the right place with the right
technology so I'm very optimistic about
our approach here moving forward
wonderful so speaking to the industry as
a whole what sustainable or circular
economy principles or practices stand
out to you as particularly impactful and
why I think a sustainable development
practices that really focus on the issue
a rather than on the solution are the
ones that I could have more impact and
be more successful and gather more
acceptance for example un environment
one of the partners in this initiative
who cannot be here
they developed an online platform in
which they help countries to find
hotspots on of unsustainable a
consumption and production practices and
I think there are many organizations
advocating a two for several issues and
many making the needs visible so the
information is out there I think
sometimes we just the focus is in the in
the right place so making a the
practices respond to solutions and
thinking of the audiences and who they
benefit I think it's the right way right
I would say I am obviously excited by a
lot of the new innovations that that are
popping up including the the winners or
the finalists of this contest but I
think what I'm probably the most jazzed
about is the new collaborations that are
popping up because when you talk about
system change or changing the paradigm
it's gonna require collaboration across
the value chain but also between the
private sector and the public sector and
that's happening so this this
collaboration with Google and si P is
one example
the foundation is launching a new
initiative around the global food system
which is helping to spearhead a
partnership between some of the leading
food brands and for global cities so
it's that sort of spirit of
collaboration that I think is really
going to drive systemic change that's
great
yeah I was gonna touch on I'll pick up
on food system I think this is an area
where I see is so much opportunity and
you know at least showed us that the
butterflied diagram as it's called at
the beginning of the presentation and I
think that whole left side of the
diagram looking at the bio cycle
presents such tremendous opportunity and
and I know one of our finalists today is
working in this space in applying
technology to reduce food waste which is
fantastic and this is something that
that I'm really personally passionate
about this is something we've been
thinking about at Google we've done a
lot of work on applying technology to
food waste in our own kitchens we're now
applying machine learning and gaining
new insights and so I see a tremendous
opportunity there and I was thrilled to
see one of our finalists really looking
at that topic and the other one that I
think we don't often focus on in these
conversations but that we really like to
bring up is the role of safe chemistry
and healthy materials that when we are
endlessly cycling material back into the
system we also need to be really
confident that that material is safe for
people and for the planet and so that's
an aspect of the circular economy that I
believe is really important and that we
have done done work with a foundation
you may have seen a paper we published
on this last year but I also see that as
a really important piece of the dialogue
and I know I met some folks in the
audience who are developing a materials
marketplace to great create more
transparency we've done a lot of work on
this particularly in the building
materials space but that's another
aspect of the circular economy that I
think is really important to focus on
out there for a business which is if you
have a supplier that's providing you
virgin materials you can ask for
form-fit function price everything
exactly to your specification if you
were looking at secondary markets for
materials what if the quality isn't what
you expect what if the quantity that
you're expecting isn't what you expect
what if the quantity and quality are
good but they show up in a location that
you
didn't expect so one of the proofs of
concepts we've run fairly recently is
really how do you do that at a
commercial scale for a large company
that's gathering these secondary market
materials and how do you tie it into
integrated business planning for your
business what happens if the quality
isn't quite there can I still get away
with making my products what do I need
to do to post-process it in order to do
that what do I need to do with my
logistics systems for just in time to
get the right quality components
together in the right place so for the
first time it's really tying it to the
core business process and tying it to
profitability as you look at that at
scale so I think there's a lot of great
examples of Circular within closed loops
within companies
there's becoming a lot of great examples
of closed loops within small ecosystems
auto manufacturers and certain battery
recyclers and parts suppliers there's
not really a good example of open
ecosystem open loops that are happening
and as we get to material marketplaces
we really need to get to that point of
increased supply and transparency to to
handle some of those risks to business
great thank you
so pivoting a little bit to talk about
technology here we are at Google cloud
next we've you know mention machine
learning and artificial intelligence but
you know what in your mind and your
opinion is the role of data and
sustainable development and in
sustainability more broadly that's also
one to start with Alonso given the
global partnership team sure I'm just
preaching to the choir but data is the
lifeblood of sustainable development
it's the way we understand the problems
we have at hand a word they're located
who are they affecting a what are the
right policies to put in place a house
to course-correct these policies and
ultimately to achieve impact so data the
data value chain crosses across the
policy-making and I think that for data
to truly power sustainable development
there's two conditions that need to be
met and one is data has to be about
social justice so oftentimes the most
marginalized people in the world are
encountered in the data they are either
a Miss by censuses and surveys
they are hidden behind statistics and
averages and in order for data to be
truly about sustainable development it
has to be about all and for all and the
second condition I think it's for data
to be a public good so oftentimes data
or lately data is referred as the new
oil I think this this is this framing
just kind of conceals the power of data
data is infinite data increases value as
it's used and it's collated with other
data and if the right standards policies
and infrastructure are put in place data
can truly be a public good keep mixing
it up I'll go the other thing I think is
incredibly important is getting people
the right data at the right time as
they're making a decision becomes vital
you can have the best state in the world
and if it's not there when you're acting
on it it's not gonna be helpful so our
team in the UK ran a project called the
plastics challenge last year it was a
guy named Steve Jameson Michele Hickey
great great work they followed consumers
around not in a creepy way but in a
gathering data kind of way for about a
month and gauged their every interaction
with plastic I get up in the morning I
eat my yogurt I throw the aluminum lid
away I tossed the cup here I grab my
plastic water bottle I go to the gym
what do I do with that all and out of
that through partnerships we ran a
three-day design think and came up with
a lot of cool solutions but if you come
up to me afterwards I've got one app
that is really interesting and what it
does is it takes the idea of the data
that's collected around this puts it
into a machine learning algorithm so
with your phone you can snap a picture
of a water bottle and know what it's
made out of it's PE T o and then it'll
use geolocation to know where you are
and know what the options for recycling
that water bottle is a consumer might be
within that region so this is up and
running in the UK and it's one example
of putting data in the right hands to
make a decision at the right time we
just announced last week the the pr went
out with bumblebee tuna doing blockchain
traceability with tune
again a really cool app and it allows
you to look at scan a barcode on your
tuna that you're buying and it will show
you exactly where that fish was caught
what the fisherman's lifestyle was like
what the normal catch for that product
is whether it's endangered and then with
the company the fair trade implications
of that like oh this is a community that
we're providing gloves for so they don't
hurt their hands when the when the lines
come in all super valuable data at the
right time is you're making a consumer
buying decision and then it has to be
fun too so if you go to the next page
it's got recipes for how you use all
that delicious tuna so it's combining
kind of the traceability and the social
aspects along with you know consumer
aspects and really interesting projects
I want to hear more about your take a
photo identify the product yes I totally
agree and I think just to build on that
you know the way that I think about it
is I think we're really moving from the
age of information to the age of
knowledge you know we've generated so
many data sets over the last couple of
decades but now we're able to unlock
those data sets to be really actionable
and and and I think there's tremendous
opportunity to utilize data to empower
communities to empower policymakers to
empower individuals to drive sustainable
change and one of my absolute favorite
examples of this is a project that we
worked on with two wonderful ngos Oceana
and sky truth which is called global
fishing watch and so this is one of
these amazing examples of we were able
to take this huge global data set which
is that every ship that is on the high
sea is constantly pinging out its
location every day and so we were able
to take that data set and with the
machine learning algorithm recognize
what did a fishing boat look like as
compared to a cruise ship or a tugboat
or any other kind of vessel and then
what it actually looked like when it was
fishing and then we utilized our massive
cloud compute and our geo mapping
capabilities to create a real-time heat
map of where is global fishing activity
taking place and then communities have
been using this data to create marine
protected areas so there's actually five
new marine protected areas that have
been created just since we launched this
tool a few years ago and it's enabling
community
to take control of their resources to
drive towards conservation and to
partner with the fishing communities to
also enable them but to do it in a much
more sustainable way so just one example
that I love but I think of really
putting that data in people's hands so
they can drive really positive
sustainable action so also follow up on
on technology so what are the
opportunities to leverage in addition to
the examples that you shared the
leverage modern technology especially
machine learning and AI for a
sustainable future what can we do today
I think it'd be great to hear some you
know insights from the AI and the
circular economy report that went out
just a few months ago yeah absolutely
so I alluded to this a little bit but we
we did a report that we published I'm
just back in January with the Ellen
MacArthur Foundation and with McKinsey
of really looking at this intersection
point of circular economy and AI and we
particularly did a drill down into into
the food system and into consumer
hardware and I think some of our major
takeaways were the ways in which sort of
as we've been talking about AI can help
us to drive new insights so for example
we looked at the opportunity for to
design better products and we're
starting to see examples for for
instance that European Space Agency they
have been using AI to develop better
more sustainable materials so we're
seeing that as a tremendous application
equally we're starting to see a I
applied in really interesting ways to
business models so some of you may know
the company stuff ster they're a great
circular business and they utilize
machine learning to set the price for
their products for their kind of
secondary use product so they are able
to scan what is the price for a new
product how do they set a fair price but
that also enables them to make a profit
and continue to run their business and
so we're I think we're starting to
really see that AI and particularly
machine learning can be applied to
accelerate these new business models and
and enable new insights and in fact many
of our our applicants for this contest
really showed that in exciting ways so
I'll it I really thought those insights
were useful and equally we've been
experimenting on this in Google inside
of our data centers so we took a machine
learning algorithm and applied it to our
data center cooling system and we
basically created an AI powered
efficiency recommendation system so it
looked at power temperature pump speeds
other data sets that we had for how the
cooling system was operating and then it
wouldn't it would recommend how could we
operate more efficiently and then we put
it on autopilot so then it was just
making those recommendations on its own
and getting a 30% increase in efficiency
and are already very highly optimized
data centers and I love that example
because it means we can deliver cloud
even more sustainably but also it points
to the huge opportunity that machine
learning presents to optimize many other
systems so those are just some of my
favorite examples yeah I think Cates
grabbed all the all the good ones we're
doing stuff in similar areas that one I
would add is logistics and the ability
to move things around much more
efficiently look at loads look at the
way factories operate and kind of pour
on business which i think is vitally
important I got back I'm you know kind
of a funny aside but from you talking
about the data centers I got back from
our shanghai labs and they've got this
all set up within the coffee machine so
if your milk is running low somebody
gets a warning and it can predict which
machines and what milk times so you know
simple examples like that of real world
experience we've done it in our
Vancouver labs around the trash bins to
know when the when the recycle and when
the trash is is getting full and learned
some real-world results from that like
in a mobile environment like that the
sensors might not be as robust as you
would want them to to be but I think I
think the big areas are within within
logistics certainly it's within
dematerialization it's looking at ways
of moving contracts around rather than
moving containers around if you have
similar things with different companies
in different areas so and I think we're
really all just scratching the surface
on the potential so this contest was a
great way to work with a number of
companies that have some brilliant ideas
the space and figure out ways to make
those reality and what I would add to
that taking it back to the very high
level is is when I think about the
evolution of our foundation we spent
five years basically just trying to get
the message out creating a framework
mobilizing folks around that message
we've needed to evolved because the
debate has now or the acceptance level
of that message has led us to to need to
put those principles into practice we've
said things that were again very high
level things like waste plus information
equals an asset actually putting a
phrase like that into practice is an
extremely difficult thing and it's only
through partnerships and interest from
companies like si P and Google and some
of the advances that have happened in
computing and AI and machine learning
over the last couple years makes that a
reality and Jim mentioned the app of
taking a photo of plastic and and
advancements in image recognition allows
you now to basically take a photo of
waste and rethink what that means what's
what or it allows you to make that link
between the physical world and the
digital world and that opens up just an
enormous amount of possibilities to get
that waste to places situations where
it's got a value and by definition isn't
waste anymore that's great thank you I'm
so also a follow up question on
something that we touched on briefly
before that I discussed in the
presentation earlier the SDGs we've been
talking about sustainability we've been
talking about the circular economy but
digging a little bit deeper into the
sustainable development goals and
especially into SDG twelve responsible
consumption and production what would
you say is one of the or some of the
challenges unique to SDG twelve what is
something that needs to be addressed
today in order to achieve that goal by
2030 we would love to hear your thoughts
on that Alonso thanks of course at least
am
I think what's interesting about the
SDGs is that they present a B while
their individual goals in the end it's a
comprehensive picture of all the things
we need to tackle in order to achieve
long lasting change
so all these goals are inter
interconnected to each other so for
example as DG 12 cannot be achieved if
we don't also work on gender equality
and protecting the environment and
resources and for example a many other
things but I think the challenges and I
talked about our work we we think about
this all the time how it's not only
about the technical barriers but also
the political ones and I think as g2 has
the same things it like it requires a
more coordination at the national level
ensuring kind of the right approach a
scientific evidence obviously the use of
data bringing different stakeholders
together to innovate and think of new
ways to improve consumption and
production so once again in order to
kind of work towards a circular economy
we need to think of the broader picture
right and how all of this is connected
to each other so for the non geeks in
the audience when you put environmental
people together with technology people
you get an awful lot of acronyms SDG 12
sustainable development goal is about
the production and consumption you know
as Elise said and for the geeks on stage
that have that have douve into the
details it has some sub targets on like
having food waste in the world so two of
our winners are looking at the food
waste is a major issue one from a
developing country perspective one from
a developed country perspective same
issue two very different solutions to
how you address that it's got a goal of
reducing chemical wastes it's got a goal
of reducing waste in general to me the
one that's most interesting is there's a
goal in an aspiration for companies to
report publicly on a sustainability data
and this is where I think you get the
biggest bang for the buck is actually
tying financial data for corporate
reporting to environment in social data
and at si P were on year 8 now of our
integrated report where we're reporting
all of that but we're looking at the
environment and the social impact on our
company in reporting that out on how it
affects our profitability so I'd
encourage you to take a look at that we
just put a new report out a couple of
weeks ago and we've got a diagram where
you can transparently follow the flows
of which of our KPIs as a corporation
not environment and social affect each
other and some of them like employee
retention has a fairly big effect on
profitability if we lose 1% of employees
it's 55 to 65 million dollars in
profitability hit for that so it's a
really good way of tying together
environment and social along with core
financial performance and it's one that
I think more and more companies need to
do because it really helps steer the
company to make the right decision for
financial reasons which also has a
pretty big economic environment and
social great well thank you so thinking
about the finalists they've come up in
the conversation today you mentioned
food waste in particular I'm looking at
their applications and at their
proposals
what from their proposals was
particularly noteworthy for you and
assessing them and in your opinion what
was innovative what is their potential
to drive the impact at scale well I mean
as I said I I'm thrilled about all the
finalists and frankly I think there were
many other really strong applications
and I think what what I really
appreciated about them you know hysteria
and said it was just the wide variety of
applications the geographic diversity
from you know looking at the food system
totally more technical materials like
batteries I was really heartened by how
representative all of the finalists were
of the many different opportunities and
areas that we can innovate and so I was
particularly excited about that and as I
sort of hinted at I've gotten really
interested in the food system and I was
really excited to see that focus in the
food system because you know let's face
it a third of food
getting wasted we have to figure this
out and I think technology has such a
critical role to play and also it was
just so heartening to see you know how
people are thinking about using our
technology and of course that's atps
technology too because we ask ourselves
this question all the time how can we
utilize Google technology to enable more
sustainable outcomes and you all thought
of things that we had never thought of
before so that too was I thought just
really exciting to see and I would say I
don't have a favorite as well I think at
the foundation we focus on material
flows and when you look around the world
at the important or at least the the key
material flows that we need to tackle as
as an economy you look at textiles you
look at food waste as s Kate mentioned
you look at e waste and you ask the
question are we using resources the
resources that we have in the most
effective way possible and I think all
of these applicants all these finalists
have figured out how to do that or at
least have a model that gets us to start
attacking that so all all really cool
all great applicants looking forward to
seeing over the next six months bring
absolutely so we're getting close on
time and definitely want to allow some
time for questions but as a lightning
round quickly closing question for the
group what is one thing that everyone
today can do to be more sustainable and
to minimize their footprint you know I
was thinking about that earlier when you
wouldn't you first threw that at me
and I think whether you know you're a
business or an individual every decision
really comes down to two key questions
that you need to ask about a product or
a thing whether you're producing it or
using it one is is how is that thing
going to be used and then to what's
gonna happen once it's done being used
and I think just having that in your
head can really go a long way to to
helping you or your company make better
choices that's great and and I think you
know of course so many opportunities for
us to solve these challenges and drive
solutions at work but also
I think bringing this home with us is so
powerful and I always get so excited I
feel like I've had so many people
recently tell me how much their kids are
interested in this topic and I think you
know this is their future as Jim said so
I think bringing this home and engaging
with your family you know doing
composting at home ensuring your
recycling looking at bringing you know
green cleaning products into your home
thinking about more sustainable ways of
you know getting to work or getting your
family to you know an outing on the
weekend I think these can feel like
really small decisions but they really
do add up and I think it's an
opportunity for all of us to lead by
example and to really partner with the
next generation and see this behavior
really early because if we all do this
stuff the world would look very
different I have to agree it's about
like those consumption decisions and
whenever like confronting a new buy or
purchase just thinking of where is it
coming from and how does it affect
someone like either someone who's
producing it and as I said like at the
end of the lifecycle of that product
worse it going to end up but also like
asking do I really need that thing that
I'm going to buy I think that's really
important and well it's hard to always
having to think and rationalize every
purchase that we make it's it's
important it's those small changes that
really add up I agree and I think the
more we can know in not getting to
techniques like Marie Kondo or like the
clutter or life or things like that
because we're constantly asking these
questions would be great yeah speed
around I have two really quick things
but one is in personal life so I have
another confession to make I'm a
musician and I like collecting cool
instruments and it became a problem you
know a few years ago but I've put into
place for my own purchasing a one in one
out rule so if I want to buy anything
whether it's a new symbol or a sweater
or something I need to decide what I'm
gonna donate in order to buy that and it
really changes your mindset in
purchasing because I might think I
really like something but when I I think
of what I have and what I would get rid
in order to acquire that a lot of times
I'll just say you know I don't really
need that so just one personal little
interesting hack it works with food too
at the end of the week with my daughter
we do a pasta a la refrigerator and we
go through and we have to invent a
recipe with all of the food that we're
gonna have to throw out the next day in
order to make a new a new dish
so there's innovative ways to do that
without sacrificing but just making more
conscious decisions and the final thing
I would say is when you're making
purchase decisions when you're giving
somebody your hard-earned cash you have
the ability to ask hard questions and
make choices and don't always make them
on the value of the transaction make
them on the values of the company you're
transacting with for the long term and
just those two things will I think
really help change behaviors I guess the
final thing I would say too is that the
reason why we talk so much about systems
design and changing the system is
because we don't want people to make
sacrifices when we think about SDG 12 or
responsible consumption or however you
want to term it
we don't want Jim to buy less cool
guitars we just want the old guitars to
go to the right place and you know if we
can create those kinds of systems then
there aren't really bad choices but but
again that's a tall order and that's a
that's a huge left so we would say that
that's a long-term project and but but
that is that's the end goal wonderful
thank you so much
[Music]